hi this is dr gregory sadler
i'm a professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years
and i find that many people run into
difficulties reading classic
philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
in the very last section of her article
the trolley
problem judith jarvis thompson
introduces
a new wrinkle into it which from the
vantage point of the present where this
has become
a set of memes and been transformed into
a number of other new scenarios
really applies much more and that is
when there's what she calls a villain a
bad
agent who is threatening others
who is setting up the situation we might
think about the classic
dilemmas imposed on batman by the joker
save these people or save
these people batman didn't create the
situation
and somebody else the villain in this
case you know
typically a villain the joker did that
and we could think of all sorts of other
action movie similar scenarios where you
know save one
or save five and the protagonist the one
who makes the decision
did not place themselves or these people
into that situation
when we think about the trolley problem
meme people are tied down to the tracks
right and so
somebody tied them down to the tracks
there's actually one
where it's a philosophy professor who
has done that
in their imagination in order to be able
to do moral dilemmas and so that would
make somebody like judith jarvis
thompson or virginia held
or all their followers afterwards down
this this
track pun intended into villains of this
sort
but what we're talking about here in her
view is
a scenario like this suppose a villain
says to us
i will cause a ceiling to fall on five
unless you send lethal fumes into the
room of one
now that's identifiable as one of the
earlier scenarios that she
has examined that that virginia held
also brought up
in which case there's a ceiling that
could fall in on people
unless you use some sort of device which
will cause
fumes which would have to be pumped into
some other
patient's room and it'll kill that one
person
and she says well you you can't actually
do that because you're not diverting
a threat from the five
on to the one you're actually creating a
new threat in this case
we have an agency we have a villain who
says
i'm setting things up like this so this
is what we can call a situation
of forced choice where somebody else
is responsible for the situation being
like that and so what happens when we
introduce villains
into the mix villains who create
situations villains who
threaten and then we have to make the
decisions does that change
the morality of these various problems
that she
is is examining and the question here is
do we and this is the word that she uses
exceed to that is
give into the threat and do
what the villain requires us to do
or do we refuse the order that the
villain is giving and say
that's your responsibility i'm not going
to do what you
said it would be morally wrong for me to
do it or it's not
permissible or something like that
and she says that we can think about
villains in several different ways
the first way that she talks about which
is quite interesting
i think it's kind of a cop-out and i
think she does too
she says we could think of villains as
essentially just part of the world
around the people
involved a part which is going to drop a
burden on the five
if we do not act now from a practical
perspective
maybe that is the way that you would
look at it let's say if you were
engaged in some sort of policing and
you have to act very quickly you say
listen we already know that the villain
is gonna do what they say they're gonna
do and we're not worried about whether
they're
right or wrong we just need to save
lives as much as possible and
adopt a sort of you know utilitarian
perspective or the
rights trump's utility perspective that
she has
involved here in this case were in some
respects
abstracting from the moral
responsibility
of the bad agent the the villain
but you know that might be a tempting
thing to do she says
on this way of thinking of him nothing
yet threatens the five certainly no
ceiling
as yet threatens him why because the
villain is the one who's going to bring
the ceiling down
on them and ah fortiori we cannot save
the five by making what already
threatens them instead threaten the one
i don't actually think that's right if
the villain can be presumed to have an
iron will and
to follow through on whatever threats
that they made
then and we're treating them essentially
like a mechanism it seems like they
then once the threat has been issued we
do have a
a live threat we do have a similar
problem of is it okay to
divert the the death on to the one even
though it's not the same thing
threatening them the other thing is we
can consider the villain
him or herself as a threat to the five
and she says but sending the fumes in is
not making
him be a threat to the one instead of
the five
rather it's making uh
what would we call it the villain's will
be the threat
um and that's you know that that's an
interesting point as well
i think that could be explored a little
bit further
again considering temporality which is
something that she does
arrive at towards the very end of this
she then brings up the difference
between
cases right and she
she says that in in these sort of cases
we
we should not exceed why because the
hypothesis i propose says nothing about
the source a threat to the five
whether the threat to the five is or is
caused by a human being it's not
permissible to do what will kill one to
save the five except by making what
threatens the five itself threatened one
so then what if we have a case like the
trolley problem
like the traditional trolley problem
now in memes where we see the five
people tied to the tracks
and we see one person tied another track
and we have the bystander at the switch
and the trolley is out of control
and somebody set this up right because
they didn't tie themselves down
presumably
so she says it seems very plausible to
think if a villain has started a trolley
towards five
we may deflect the trolley towards one
other things being equal
if a trolley is headed towards five and
we can deflect it towards one we may
no matter who or what caused it to head
towards the five
in this case there's no actual threat
the villain is not saying
if you don't do this i will do this
instead the villain has just set it up
so that if we don't do this then
something else
bad is going to happen
but they haven't you could say there's
an intentionality
there but you know
thompson seems to think that this is
this is different and
i actually would agree with her in the
trolley case whoever has set it up
and similar sorts of things she mentions
avalanches fires
earlier on we can deflect the threat
from the five on to the one still not
good
but it's it's a better situation
what about the ceiling and fumes one
so she says suppose a villain says i'm
gonna cause the ceiling to fall on five
unless you
send lethal fumes into the room of one
if we
refuse so that he does do what he
threatens to do
then he surely does something very much
worse
than what we would be doing if we
acceded to his threat
and sent the fumes in so if we refuse
then the villain does worse in actuality
than what we would have done had we
chosen the other
alternative kills five
kills one right if we exceed
she says we do something misguided and
wrongful
but not nearly as bad as what he does
if we refuse so we would do something
that's bad
killing one right but
and that's an actuality but it's not as
bad as the potential of what he would
have
done so she says it should be stressed
the fact that he will do something worse
if we do not
send the fumes in does not entail that
we ought to send them in
or even that it is permissible for us to
do so
and she says how could that entail it
the fact that we would be saving five
lives by sending the fumes in does not
itself make it permissible for us to do
so why because
as she said earlier rights trump
utilities
how could adding that the taker of those
five lives would be doing
what is worse than we would tip the
balance
if we may not infringe the right of the
one in order to save the five lives it
cannot possibly
be thought that we may infringe the
right of that one in order
not merely to save the five lives now
here's where it gets a little
interesting and weird and she talks
about
not making the villain's moral
record better right so
again let's think this over we refuse
the villain does something really bad
their moral record
is very bad they've killed five people i
mean their moral record should also
reflect that they
created this whole situation in the
first place but she doesn't
doesn't worry about that if we give in
then the villain's moral record
is actually better because they don't
kill anybody
we kill them we kill the one person and
you know thompson says this is
this is really not okay we shouldn't
make the villain's moral record better
than it otherwise would be and this
comes up as well
in another situation that she considers
here's where we get to another
interesting point that she's making
she tells us that what is of interest
is what her holds interpersonally
also holds intra personally and you
might say what is the difference between
inter and intra well inter is between
persons right so between me and you
and the trolley driver and the villain
and the victims and all that
intrapersonally means within
a person and you might say well how can
how can you have a relation within a
person well we do all the time if i say
oh i'm making a bad decision i'm
taking a position on myself there's a
kind of an intrapersonal thing going on
there
if i feel regrets about the stupid thing
that i did
last week i'm saying past greg
you know who's also in some respect me
really did something bad there and i i
should you know
fix it or feel bad about it or something
like that and this is the case
that she considers so she says we could
imagine the surgeon of transplant to
have caused
in the past the ailments of his five
patients
let us imagine the worst he gave them
chemical acts precisely to cause their
deaths
in order to inherit from them now he
repents which means that there's a
conflict within the person right
the fact that he would be saving five
lives by operating on the one
does not make it permissible for him to
operate on the one
why she says rights trump utilities and
she might also be talking about the fact
that there's no
exemption in this case if he may not
infringe on the right of the one in
order to save the five lives it cannot
be
possibly thought that he may infringe on
the right of the one in order not merely
to save the five lives but notice what
she says here
but in order to make his own moral
record better than it otherwise would be
now this is a little puzzling isn't it
it seems like
we do things all the time in order to
make
our own moral record better
because we're flawed human beings and we
screw up and we you know have to
apologize
and make up for things make it right as
we say
in doing so are we permitted to
transgress the rights of others
so for example could i steal from a
flower shop to
to get flowers to give to my wife after
i
had an argument with her um you know i
think
thompson would say no you you should buy
the flowers right
in this case of course we have a
constricted situation where the only way
that the surgeon can
save the people who he has effectively
given a death sentence to is to take the
organs
of a victim the poor man who walked in
just coming in for a checkup who happens
to be a compatible organ donor
for these five patients and
i think that there might be a difference
between situations not like this
where we do in fact want to make our
moral record better
situations where we might contribute to
other people's moral record being better
but even if they could be a villain you
know helping uh uh
you know restorative justice when a
criminal
has uh injured somebody and and you know
destroyed their trust in society or
something like that in these situations
thompson wants to say that there's no
reason we should be trying to make
anybody's moral record better whether
it's our own
or if we're the bad you know surgeon or
the threatening person who otherwise
would kill
five and so she says another way to put
the point is assessments of which acts
are worse
than which have to be directly relevant
to the agent's circumstances if they're
to have a bearing on what
he may do if a threatens to kill five
unless b kills one
then although killing five is worse than
killing one
these are not alternatives open to b
the alternatives open to b are kill one
thereby forestalling the deaths of five
and making a's moral record better than
it would otherwise be or
let it be the case that a kills five
and the supposition that it would be
worse for b to kill the the one is
entirely compatible with the supposition
that killing five is worse than
killing one she finishes up by
considering the case of a different
surgeon
who is faced with a choice between here
and now giving chemical
x to five thereby killing them and
operating on and thereby
killing only one and she says that this
is sort of like the
you know uh trolley driver or you know
at the switch
other things being equal it does seem he
may choose to operate
on the the one some people might say
something stronger
that he's required to make this this
choice so that's that's a different
situation and it doesn't have to do with
making
somebody's moral record better it's a
dif it
she sees that as a relevant part of the
situation
so this is you know good to keep in mind
when we have agency that's malevolent
you could say
it doesn't radically change the way in
which we resolve these cases but it does
introduce some new considerations
you